en 2001 la direction de tf1 est très
remonté que love story leur soient
passés en fait voilà ça a été fait sur
machiste et il dégaine star academy la
star academy 6 lors des premiers prime
time des scores étaient timides
parce qu'au début il faut savoir que
star académie saez cohade 4007 fiasco
donc qu'est ce qui se disait à ce moment
là sur ce qu'aristote maintenant il ya
c'est plus un secret je me retrouve à la
en réunion avec tout l'état major de
télé sans et stéphane courbit donc le
producteur bien sûr que j'ai embrassé
brasse d'endémol et ont dit on va vous
rembourser
non on est désolé quand tu dis on va
vous rendre ou et jordi écouter on est
désolé on va vous rembourser j'avais
commandé convient de prendre avec ça
comment je sais pas vous avez deux mois
et demi de 10 et on leur dit bah on va
passer en deuxième partie de soirée et
on va vous rembourser
c'est incroyable et donc à ce moment là
patrick le lay le grand patron de tf1
arriver dit il ya un truc que je
comprends pas c'est des chanteurs
pourquoi il chante pas vos gamins et
enfin contre l'erreur qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on sortait du loft moi j'ai produit
le premier loft et on faisait une télé
réalité là où c'était une école de chant
et enfin quand on est sorti de cette
réunion on est on a dit vous allez
chanter et c'est là où la magie opérait
avec cette petite phrase et c'est dingue
mais c'est la première fois que
j'entends ça n'est pas que vous aviez
dit on va vous rembourser mais assez
alors on va revoir le lancement de la
saison une donc c'était un fiasco
donc la première émission scénique aux
qui présentait qui lui venaient de
france 2 il était chroniqueur chez
christine bravo à l'épauler dans l'union
libre et vous l'aviez débaucher qui a eu
l'idée de nikos c'était l'hymne des
vergès d'accord qui était directeur
d'edhec était directeur des programmes
et la texture de tf1 exact regarde
bonsoir
soyez le bienvenu en direct nous sommes
il est exactement 29 53
vous avez entendu parler c'est dans des
torts de star académie aujourd'hui c'est
le grand soir
bienvenue soyez le bienvenu à star
académie
[Applaudissements]
et remarquez nikos et le disent et
alexia il a toujours la main bras même
quand il est né l'a fait pop comme un
égal mais c'est la techno mais bon les
séries on va parler de tout ça dans un
instant quand je sais que ça réagit
énormément 1 sur les réseaux sociaux on
va parler de l'île de la tentation aussi
la star academy je suis encore d'autres
d'extraits aprilia une explique paul
baysse people la ferme célébrités après
ces faits en afrique j'ai fait
exactement et après c'était jean pierre
foucault et christophe dechavanne bien
et moi non c'est moi mais surtout la
première compagnie qui était un immense
oui anton et norbert la bombe a été le
plus gros est ce que c'est on dirait qu
à star académie ce que tu nous a raconté
un instant alexia c'est un énorme four
au début moi j avais complètement oublié
je pense que les téléspectateurs aussi
moi j'étais persuadé que ça avait
cartonné dès le début et en fait non et
on se rappelle que la première gagnante
c'était une chéri de jennifer et oued
jennifer et a gagné ya plein de gens qui
ont vu le lancement de nikos tout à
l'heure et nikos a démarré l'émission
disons il est 20 heures 53
il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit oui
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque les prime
commence la maintenance est aujourd'hui
bien sûr à 20h53 on est dans le dur avec
le magicien à torcy or là on a flingué
la télé avant de tout flinguer on a
gravi voudrait coup de pub est arrivé
c'est du passé
les chéris donc la gagnante de la
première saison c'est donc la jeune
jennifer qui a donc par la suite une
carrière exceptionnelle regarder le
portrait de jennifer et regardez ce
qu'ils lisent ça c'est un truc qu'on
n'aurait jamais pu dire maintenant mais
je vous dis on écoute et bien un moment
et après qu on s'est dit ah ouais bon ça
ça passe à l'époque mais là ce serait
fait défoncer mardi à 18 ans jennifer a
déjà un sacré tempérament
débordant de l'énergie est toujours
enjoué cette belle niçoise a décidé de
prendre la vie du bon côté
j'ai dit à cent à l'heure je bouge tout
le temps j'adore la vie je lève je crois
que la plaine d'anvers est aujourd'hui
jennifer n'a rien perdu de sa souplesse
pour canaliser son trop plein de
vitalité
elle se défoulent dans le sport
au programme fitness box et footing ce
qui lui permet aussi de surveiller sa
ligne s'écrit sur lui c'est toute la
poitrine elle trouve à 10 et non mais
c'est vrai le poids c'est incroyable et
là ils disent surveiller sa ligne à la
fin ils terminent 6es d'un coût de 90 et
non mais franchement alexia à l'exacte
quoi fouetter un bonnet d je fais un
bonnet f
ouais parce que eddy énorme et cheyrou
on avait pas on descend c'est aussi une
bonne chose mais elle était tellement
choupinette quand je la vois là mais
tels les chevaux journée abidal ça peut
être que boney m
voilà merci voilà pour les personnes
d'écouter rtl et qui nous regarde pas sa
job ça fait jamais de mal
wi2wi oui et tu passes après et laurent
ruquier camions nous chercher et à
l'oeil à l'issue de cette première
saison c'est jenifer qui l'emportent
et puis c'est comme vous avez fait
téléspectateurs en finale 11 millions de
téléspectateurs jennifer bon rappelle
moi j'ai été jetée padovan j'étais pas
devant mais je voyais les gens je me
rappelle très bien parce que j'étais au
casino vous jure que c'est vrai j'étais
au casino et les gens parler de la
finale de la star ac comme dans un match
de foot
abbas devrait donc je crois que c'est
jennifer qui a gagné avec jean vraiment
une ébullition c'est quand jennifer a
gagné c'est un truc de fou matin avec ma
mission oui comme ça maintenant tu dis
quoi tu diras mais qu'il a fait trois
fois questions pour un champion est
reparti avec un cd rom non gardé
cette voie
[Applaudissements]
la liste est longue
vous
remporter
[Musique]
la première star academy
nikos je pense qu'il n'a jamais dit
autant le prénom thierry on l'avait
compris
c'est nikos cabaye a pas semblé inquiet
des fleurs jennyfer jennifer jennifer
hedger louis costes a toujours
l'impression qu'il est dans un film
d'horreur blessés les films d'horreur
américains à quand tu rentres dans la
maison téléphone jeff a cédé fort ce
plan qui se cachent dans les costumes ni
côte c'est ça qu'on aime c'est que
balsillie
tu vois ça aurait peut être par là
mondiale qui présente d'astarac ah non
si ça m'aurait plu c'est vrai est
beaucoup moins tf1 à l'époque vous
seriez très aurait été très bon non mais
c'est vrai que ça j'aime moi j'aime tout
ça il adore mais il adore la chanson il
adore l'argent oui on était tous a
tellement à fond dans sa gamme eee
aujourd'hui encore vingt ans après on se
souvient que jennifer a promis une
voiture rouge à mario c'est pas si elle
est offert ou pas ouais c'est vrai alors
c'est vrai qu'il lui avait promis une
voiture est ce que tu sais ce que tu vas
pas me demander ça lui a offert la
bagnole j'en sais rien du tout c'est la
voiture ap ap jennifer non non mais si
il s'était plaint après lui et ses
hommes avaient alors il sera avec nous
demain mario donc il nous dira ou demain
ou après-demain failback dire très vite
peut-être pas sérieuse que c'est shabbat
mais peut-être dans voilà c'était aussi
qu'il y avait le mauvais élève
moi je me rappelle surtout le casting on
a fait tous les castings de chanteurs
pierre moment je regardais jeudi
j'aimerais bien avoir un mauvais élève
un fond de classe quoi le mec à côté du
radiateur qui n'attendent pas et tout et
moi je viens du pays basque et là j'ai
dit un basque jean pascal et c'est là
jean pascal et jean pascal a vendu mais
je sais pas combien un million c'est moi
même
jean prat clair avec nous demain bien
entendu jean pascal ou journée
incroyable alors